hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil
village we just escaped
we just escaped we um
temporarily departed lady dempt rescue
and castled him at rescue and we are
going into some weird church
i think doesn't look like anything
normal that i have seen
but i'm assuming that everything is fine
yeah let me just open a coffin
this always turns out great and places
where there are vampires uh-oh
hey just wanted to interrupt for a
second to say that bob wade and i made a
new podcast called
distractible if you ever wanted to go
off on random tangents talking about
whatever random [ __ ] you wanted to
talk about
why not listen to our podcast where we
do exactly that and then we have a
little competition to see who can
win the best at arguing their [ __ ]
and then the winner gets to be the host
of the next podcast next week
so if that interests you there's a link
in the description below where you can
check that out
and now back to the video because i
don't want to waste too much of your
time but please be aware the link in the
description below and you can click that
anytime
you can finish watching this video
though and that'd be totally cool but
i'm just going to get out here now okay
thank you
okay there i go with the stabbing here
you go
[Music]
hey fares play oh come on
[Applause]
i'm sorry
now see that's some power that i can
respect
that's uh i always knew there was
potential
[Music]
wow okay
am i supposed to be doing something um
okay apparently i'm finished
all right well thank you
i don't know about finish you didn't
really finish the job there but uh okay
oh well i don't have a sniper rifle but
i didn't need one
uh how am i doing on ammo anyway not
great
um can i craft some yeah
[Applause]
all right okay uh
lady demidom is this your dimmadome oh
boy
am i safe in here probably not
what does that mean
i mean it's pretty cool for him you
gotta admit it's not bad
not what i would for what
what did i do i opened a window
that's all i did why are you so mad
oh i see okay i gotta i got a bonker on
her nog
uh-huh okay cool well i got my hidey
hole here so
easy for me
okay bye oh i can i can still hit you
from there
seems a little easy you know i'm not
gonna lie here oh are you doing
something were you
oh you're vulnerable i think this might
be a vulnerable stage
oh wait never mind i missed it
okay bye
okay
ow
technically you tried to take things
from me oh whoops
well you didn't do a good job in
actually hating me but all right i'll
forgive you uh
oh hey what's up
oh
oh wow okay yeah let me restore my whole
splagoosh
uh
hello oh boy
uh no
okay well that's weird
[Applause]
am i doing something here
seems like i'm i'm going to hell kill
you
seems like i'm about to hell kill
oh hi how'd you get over there
[Music]
am i supposed to be shooting might be
one of those things where i'm not
actually supposed to be shooting
okay all right well this is all
wonderful and lovely
well i didn't i didn't come here to
escape i came here for the shoddy guns
don't be shy
my terror uh lady
we just met you
hang on hold on one second hold it hold
on
hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on
you know falls don't really do nothing
to me
in fact there's very little that
actually does anything to me for some
reason
not 100 sure
i'm not sure that was actually related
to matriscus
uh nah as you see i don't know that was
her just because i got a giant crystal
statue of her
well well well well well well look at
this beautiful
beautiful beautiful i'm not gonna sell
that not on your life
not on your life not on my life not in
your life anyway
yeah now she'll be back i think she'll
be back
oh yeah all right so i can't wait to see
lady dimmit rescue again which i'm sure
will happen towards the end of the game
hey what's this
a battery hmm
uh oh indiana jones style giant rock
gonna come out
giant lady you gotta come out of this
place oh why was that the way to get out
i got a dirty flask here you give us
your dirty flask i got i got a dirty
flask
okay eve okay
some kind of thing in there i mean it's
obviously like biological science of
some kind
very much akira style um
yeah all right
rose yeah rose my daughter i forgot
drawbridge oh am i really done with the
castle oh
i mean i'll be back i'll be back of
course i'll be back i'll always have
something to remember lady didn't rescue
from
i finished that item that was requested
please deliver to the house with the red
chimney
go through the caves to the ruins then
down into the village also can i get
that knife back
i kind of want to know where that uh
where that went that was a very useful
knife
kind of a really useful knife you know
how you said no one really knew where
that was well
it was actually very easy to find um
so if you could just get that to me
that'd be great
land in the turlock gun powder in the
turret that makes sense
okay so i don't know what the deal is
with these winches but i still don't
have what i need
onto less entertaining bosses oh
what do i not have a key for that okay
well then where do i go
oh i hit it okay well that should have
been very obvious
i mean that was a pretty weak lock
it looked a lot sturdier hey hey yeah
hey yeah
hey yeah you can run nowhere oh
sorry okay
yeah yeah yeah where'd you go buddy
where'd you go your friends are dead
your friends are dead your friends are
dead give it up
give it up fish winters you'll never see
your family again
okay what did it what does this what
does this do what a
cannot be eaten as is well i wasn't
planning on it but
all right i don't know why i did that
but okay there we
within go endless dark to deliver
us into fates old lady kaboom
as the midnight moon rises on black
wings
we await the light at the end in life
and in death glory to mother miranda
oh hey remember me i almost died up at
that castle
tell me what is going on around here
how can a man be almost dead
that's a question for the wise oh my god
you know what i mean and i still haven't
found rose where did mother miranda take
her
[Laughter]
you're too late or maybe
almost too late the child will be
sacrificed
life for life what kind of sick medieval
[ __ ] is this
she's just a baby the crests of the four
bloodlines
may open the path you seek
will you please stop talking in riddles
i just want to find my daughter
it's only original if you don't know the
answer
yeah that's that's the point right
okay thanks yeah that looks familiar
yeah hey hey wait
oh no i'll never get through that door
no way oh she really got me on that one
yeah that chris looks familiar hmm that
one's vaguely familiar
don't know that one don't know that one
okay cool hey can i have this
clearly yes all right later nerd
you have fun with your riddles that
aren't actually
riddles uh kaboom
winged key
i'm gonna find my daughter eventually
don't know what happened to mia mia's
gonna show up pissed off at some point i
have a good feeling about that
that is like a hundo percent mia's is
gonna come in like gangbusters
real mad
hello oh wow yeah no
this is uh this is normal
yeah uh-huh uh-huh umbrelli
umbrelli this battery looks really
familiar i wonder why
i wonder why
okay nice tootsies uh
later nerds see you around never
oh hi oh okay it's one of those
valleys yeah okay all right
oh oh it's werewolvey time
hey what's up yo my niece your boy
marky moo here hey what's up hey good to
see you again hey look
[Applause]
this gun's a little better than it was
last time we saw so
yeah the other monsters heads didn't
explode as much as you guys do
boom
[Laughter]
bunch of nerds bunch of nerds where did
that knife go
it had to have fallen around here
somewhere it fell down from the castle i
bet
if i know where that is in relation to
where i am
i bet eventually i could find it unless
it's scripted to come across it at some
point
which it might be who knows hey what's
up dude
yup
hey bud i'm gonna stab you
oh it lags right then there really
you're gonna these guys and their
ability to attack my frame rate is
really starting to get annoying
[Applause]
you're pissing me off my dude
you're starting to piss me off
[Music]
okay i didn't know that that was gonna
do that
hi
all right well i'm not done thank you
for making that overly dramatic
i'm just assuming that there's going to
be other stuff in here
yep i was right
okay if it doesn't fit that lock what
does
okay if it doesn't fit that lock
okay none of these locks fit okay well
that's interesting um and then down this
way
oh i have no crank why is everything i
need a goddamn crank nothing's ever set
up in the way that it should be set up
it's like
no one ever actually lives here i mean i
don't know if you can call
werewolves actually living here but all
the people that used to be here i guess
actually you know you know it makes
perfect sense because if you were
running away from monsters you would
take all the tools that allow them to
make the most progress
that does actually make sense i'm not
going to question that at all hi this
looks special how's it going to kill me
yeah alter another one okay oh there you
are
i had a feeling you would pop up here
it was all worthless is that so
i assume you've picked up something of
value
not sure if it's a value but
why you have your daughter right in your
own hands
what are you saying take a closer look
oh don't drop it flask seems to contain
her head
roses don't say another word
this this is impossible this just can't
be
your daughter's essence is still intact
her powers are truly unique
who could even do this she can be saved
you know
saved from this are you insane
there's a house with a red chimney on
the western side of the village
go and seek out the man who lives there
then we can continue our conversation
quit holding out and get to the damn
point
you don't have to trust my words
but do you have any better options
your choice the customer is always
right after all
he'll pay you if i find out this is a
lie
uh-huh okay you know i killed well i
didn't kill lady dimitrisku she
she's taking vacations she's taking a
nice vacation anyway i'm not selling
this i'm actually keeping that
uh very very nice but i can get rid of
these now
well you know when lady democracy comes
back she'll probably want a lot of these
things do you want some fish
you want some fish you want fish okay
more bullets
might as well yes
i can see why you'd be interested in
that now can you you can see why
oh that's so expensive why is it so
expensive why is it so expensive
man who cares about those uh have a
wonderful adventure
okay careful you don't fall out i don't
know how you even got here
i will have a wonderful adventure but
not because you said so
because i choose to okay
so there's something there oh i'm back
in town okay
so this is actually back towards town
interesting
okay so there's a house with a red
chimney
it might have been the red chimney with
the yellow stripes around it because
that actually
was a thing oh
i'm here okay
interesting all right so i wonder if i
go back and i
actually unlock all of those doors and i
kind of open up all the paths
because each of these kind of led to
something that was a little bit um
blocked off from the last time i was
here and who knew this was all right
here
all right it's decorated with a four
winged being
oh they're different
oh they're a little different is this
the same though
huh four wings okay so this one just had
the two wings
so i need a four-winged key or i need to
modify this key or something like that
okay i see how it is all right so my
objective is find house with red chimney
there is house with red chimney
how do i get in-house with red chimney
what was that
it's got to be a way to sneak in this
place right
there's another door over there how did
i get in here in the first place
oh actually let me go in this house
because there's that
there's the lockpick thing
haberski hello hi how are you
i don't know if this is actually going
to be anything of use
nah i mean seven shotgun shells i'm not
gonna complain about it but
it's not exactly a critical story item
okay so if it wasn't up that way i know
the house is right there
that's obvious so there must be a way
around to get into it
whoo bestie
elena hello oh
all right
hmm peekaboo anybody home
okay kind of quiet
i heard a scream from the house with the
chimney i was gonna take a look but the
way was blocked by de bris
going to have to take the long way
around who would have thought that the
hole in the stable walls would come in
handy
if i'm not back by morning you should go
to louise's house alone
father who's father
who is the father is that papa is that
elena's papa
more shotgun that's always appreciated
okay there's this thing
mother miranda
mother miranda okay
hmm suspiciously looks like a goat
who was that that really startled me
i don't know why someone taking a mean
[ __ ] okay
someone cramped out some scrap
okay
easy peasy oh oh
hey what's up dude
bang ka boom let's craft some bullets
i'm gonna run out of crafties
i wish i had better oh hi dude i wish i
had a better knife
okay i don't know what wait a minute
what what is this doing here also you
know i never even questioned why did
chris take the baby in the first place
was chris working with these things
in some way like we knew chris was also
like weirdly with the umbrella
corporation at the end of resident evil
but why was why would he be working with
these guys
why would he need to why would he need
my baby
why would any of them need my baby why
would that even be a thing
i mean maybe he wasn't trying to
transport it over to these guys but
kind of seems like he was generally in
this area anyway
also why did we even move here in the
first place that's another question
why specifically here right on the
outskirts of some horrible happening
where there's literally like a castle
full of demons do not enter
you can't tell me what to do you're not
the boss of me
oh what is that
look out the wind i don't wanna
oh [ __ ] oh
oh oh oh oh
yeah uh-huh come at me bro
not today bro
i blocked it
i hate you so much i hate you i hate you
so much
come on try me try
i was blocking
i hate you i hate you i hate you so much
excuse me i was looking at something
okay so
uh 070408
0.70408 is that what we're looking for
here
ah it is oh my god
oh seven oh
four
probably just did it because they didn't
want people cycling through whoa
oh oh but i spent all my money upgrading
my other pistol
oh
this seems so much better how do i even
i can't even put my charm on that one
okay whatever also what else did i get i
got i got some kind of other item but i
was
so a jack handle
i'm gonna jack the [ __ ] out of this
stuff
yeah i saw you
yeah i saw you oh okay you want play
you all want who wants some you and then
you oh you got some accessory
some splash come at me
try you didn't try hard enough
get stabbed hard hard to fight back when
you don't have a head
loser idiot
oh can i do this now with this is the
jack also going to work on this
all right then fine
how about this then jack handle
whoa look at it go
that's quite a jack can i crawl
this seems safe
it's fine
can i help you who did that i thought
someone jumped up on there
hey cut it out nerd stop being a nerd
nerd point
go on
bang your head's gone
you know what you you monoi mono me
how many how many come on there you go
there you go
all right i'm just gonna head towards
the the red chimney place
hi what's uh what's up
you guys you guys you guys up to
something
you guys having fun you guys
you guys want you guys want me to just
shoot you then i guess
seven bullets oh my god
all right good thing i got rid of that
sniper rifle i feel really strongly
about that
yeah i definitely wouldn't be blasting
these guys off the roof
oh no no don't do any like bull charge
oh he's gonna bull charge me
he's so gonna bull charge me he's bull
charging me
ah take this oh i got you [ __ ] did i
get you
oh yeah i did oh yeah i did oh yo you're
just a dude
you're just a dude you're kind of a
bigger dude but you're just a dude
you're just a dude oh whoa he's he's
kind of tough never mind
never mind just a dude yeah okay okay
yeah okay
okay perfect princess call okay good job
yeah i blew it into oblivion but yeah
you get a perfect crystal spell
perfectly obliviated hello i didn't know
that that was so simple that i could
just undo that before but you know now
that i know that
and that everything here is kind of
wimpy it's uh
yeah it's better okay to whom we may
concern due to the luthier's long
absence
i am keeping hold of this house key
please find me if you need it regards
joseph simon beneviento's gardener
okay i don't know what that means
hello hi
oh convenient in case you need to unlock
your poops
money thanks for keeping that out in a
box outside
well that wall's gonna really regret it
you know
i hate i hate i hate
you know what i hate i just hate i hate
i hate i hate i hate everything i hate
i hate it all right i
hate it i hate it i hate
everything hate hate all of it i hate
everything
hate it i just hate it all
i'm so very upset at myself and everyone
around me for letting me
get away with the things that i do
anyway what do we have here
oh that's hell oh a well wheel i should
have known it was a wheel
not a crank a well wheel okay
well we'll make some progress then
okay there's got to be a way through
there's a ladder there wait where's that
oh yeah
i that that was like very obvious to me
and for some reason i missed it
okay whatever okay that's great
okay cool
huh hello hi
how are you how's everyone good to see
you
don't mind if i do someone pass a large
crystal in here
stab hey what's up bam
chicken chicken chicken
oh i'm sorry i thought i could oh i can
i don't know why
i'm doing that but it just feels like
something to do
now you get to live okay so now i got a
path back
for whatever that's worth and now i'm
finally at the
place where the red r oh my god
oh my god okay i'll go up the god damn
ladder in the back
sorry i killed your friend i actually do
feel bad about that now
not that bad though actually i don't
feel bad at all i've killed many things
in my trip here
and none of them have made me feel bad
hello
hi peek-a-boo
don't don't do that no i blocked it
[ __ ]
[ __ ] try me
stop stop oh my god
how much do you need that's what i
thought
what is this how's this gonna help me
with my daughter
i knew it you combine it with other keys
the winged key is just a single piece
three more parts are needed to make it
whole oh
well there you go again oh that's
perfect thank you for that damn it
better see the duke again yeah better
see the duke again i guess
whatever hello hi
thank you uh that's everything in here
okay unlock the front door i'm out of
here unlock this goddamn gate that i
could have clambered over i'm out of
here go back
see the duke talk to that [ __ ] and
then
bob's your uncle i'm out of here
hey uh so i spent all this time to get a
goddamn key you're gonna tell me why i
need to do that
did you learn anything i found these
feathers
now tell me how to fix this like you
said you would settle down
first you must use that key and collect
all of your little roses flasks
where are the rest of them there are
four
in total you have the one and the other
lords have the rest
lords
mother miranda is the cold calculating
ruler of this village
four lords serve under her
the first you've already met the lady
demetrius
the second lives deep in a valley of
mist the doll maker
donna beneviento
none of her playmates have ever come
back from that dangled
state
the third is moreau a being of twisted
flesh that lives in the reservoir past
the windmills
it is said that he is not the only
monster that lives in those waters
the fourth and most dangerous is
heisenberg
he works in his factory on the village
outskirts
and the project let's just say parts of
the human imagination are better left
alone
okay number one how do you know all this
number two how do you know about
my my daughter being how do you how do
you know about
her being in a bunch of flasks how do
you know so much about all this
anyway goddamn how big is this game that
is awesome that is actually legitimately
i'll do you a personal favor i've marked
the lord's locations on your map
some treasures still lurk in this
village
i'm sure each one will prove of great
use to you
why are you doing all this why it's all
part of our first-class customer service
please do come again soon uh-huh yeah
okay all right buddy
okay well that's all i have for this
episode here why is it
lady democracy
man this game actually is a lot bigger
than i thought it was but anyway
a lot of fun to be had i mean i'll
eagerly await the return of laid to
dimitry rescue which is obviously going
to happen but thank you everybody so
much for watching
hi it's me again it's now the end of the
video so you finished watching this
video and i really appreciate you
sticking around this long until the end
of this video to listen to my voice here
just wanted to remind you about
distractable which is great and awesome
and it's a podcast of me and my friends
made bob wade and i
and we talk about a lot of really
important things that you should
probably know about about the world and
the stories that are
lurking within the world that we all
live in and also lurking in the shadows
of our mind and the madness kind of
spills out so if that sounds like
something you're interested in
click the link in the description below
and check it out for yourself i think
you'll find to be very fun
or you can go to spotify or apple
podcast and search for distractible
and find it yourself but definitely go
now it's not going anywhere i'm just
trying to put a sense of urgency to this
so that you actually
feel like there's a need to do it now
and not later
but if you could do it now that'd be
great let me know what you thought down
in the comments below and as always
i will see you in the next video bye-bye